ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
dicen que es mi escenario pues hago yo
abróchense los cinturones
naciente hijos
estudié en líbero
hewitt
trabajé en algunas agencias de
publicidad aquí en tijuana
curiosamente
un supermercado fue el que me llevó a la
siembra
si yo hacía las portadas de los de las
frutas y las verduras
pero imposible se portaron buena onda
hasta me llevaron a san diego a un curso
para que aprendiera atom para que los
productos de las frutas y las verduras
se vieran curando que la manzana se
viera más roja y se verá cool y los
invitamos
llegó una agencia
y pregunto y me dijo
como discovery o sea quienes nuestras
portadas
y yo le pregunté
y yo
entre este interesante
dio una web
no no no no
y le dije
no te preguntes si tienes papeles pedís
que si quería trabajar
y dije pues pues apoyo gusto
para nós él es el cuerpo el cuento tan
largo pues me fui a los yunaites
lagarde mis zapatos
les voy a demostrar un poquito de mi
trabajo para que vean
lo voy a practicar un poquito de mis
trabajos para que vean lo que las frutas
y las verduras se convirtieron
trágicamente
2003 mi primer sueño
dragon quest no sé si es 7 para mí 7
8 soy malo para la matemática por esto
diseño
bien
vean
se ha asegurado porque una vez en el
facebook salieron todos los logos y
salió al riesgo
tijuana louis 2011 empezamos con las
peleas por comer
y pues me gustaron tantas peleas porque
pues me voy para el street fighter me
dan
en 2014 me enfadé los videojuegos y me
fui con películas tuve la bendición de
hacer dos películas este año uno es por
isabel boning y el próximo es 15
una idea y estuvo bien rara porque había
como 30 agentes en la agencia y todos
andaban que ya sabes en eeuu en
hollywood asiáticos negritos de todos
lados está el mexicano y todos sacando
ideas y del mexicano yum
a ver qué quieres hoy porque el el de
saint lazare manera
prácticamente era hacer algo que
que fuera diferente y dije pues un plus
y fin 2015 2016
y me enfadé de las películas y los
videojuegos y como un buen guerrero
azteca me ofrecía libertad y sin hacer
más publicidad con cuestión de dinero
tuve con starbucks etc etc etc etc
llegó 2018 y me enfrenté a combate
américa ahí si no eras el póster si
hacer un cover y ya nada más van a ser
todas las imágenes todo eso
se cumple un sueño hecho realidad mi
sueño más grande hacer mi propia agencia
de publicidad representando a tijuana
wow
system jogging
[Música]
para todo esto hubo retos
es fácil el primer reto fue les dije que
estudie en la ibero
[Risas]
pero no me gradué y no me mueve porque
no me gustaba simplemente la verdad es
que mis papás no tenían ferial planeta
tuve que esforzarme tres veces más
para poder comprarle a los gringos que
estamos en el mismo nivel
el segundo reto fue el racismo por
discriminación total
muy astuto los cañones los canijos es
como qué
eres muy bueno pero no nos gusta como
hablas cómo te interpretas con la gente
con los clientes racismo a ver tú
aprender los idiomas pero bueno
speak english
y más
ay no va a salir de la red
no era lo mismo
entender el idioma
americano y este es el lenguaje de la
carrera de diseño gráfico
- quiero ver no era como un combo tú
para los diseñadores era léger one de u2
sean white course
para todos estos
todo esto todo todo todo esto
llegó un tiempo una persona que le
gustaba mucho lo que hacía y me dijo una
frase muy buena un dibujo vale más que
mis palabras la cultura mexicana media
te llevará y no funcionó
estuvo era difícil llevar mi cultura
guerrera esté acá y dijeron no obedecer
las reglas las reglas como el tío sam y
pues tuve que obedecer pero el mayor
fracaso fue ser me la víctima
cuando yo descubrí cuando yo me enfrenté
a decir que no puedo ser la víctima las
cosas se me abrieron las cosas hicieron
mejores la gente empezó a reconocer
quién hace ambas leyes y empecé a crecer
en todos estos proyectos ustedes puede
decir guau qué creativo que culto
realmente la creatividad que utilicé fue
enfrentarme a los problemas la
creatividad que utilicé fue como ligar
con una persona como decirle obtén que
bueno y más ayuda que yahoo
y eso es donde usted en mi creatividad
como levantarme todos los días y
despertar
es difícil muchachos
pero nosotros como mexicanos como
latinos no sabemos de todas todas
se ponchó en allande y un pin abogan por
el internacional
a poco no
todos tenemos un regalo buenísimo
un regalo
interna
esto no estaba planeado
si lo conocemos
si lo amamos y lo respetamos
vamos a poder lograr cosas muy grandes
que se llama creatividad
eso es lo que realmente te lleva al
éxito
todos hagamos de inteligencia verso
vería matemáticas tú no tienes que ser
diseñador para ser creativo
un doctor
usa su creatividad para salvar vidas
un arquitecto
usa su creatividad
para ser mansiones casas
a este año decir
un abogado para hacer usa superti me va
a pasar justicia
los bomberos son creativos para apagar
el fuego de nuestro tijuana
eres el artista de tu vida
imagina
pinta
y hazlo en realidad muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]